Good morning, Hank.
It's Tuesday.
I got a little bit of the tiny chicken disease.
Hence, the husky voice.
So, I really loved your snow goose migration
video.
I thought it was fresh and smart and really
just lovely, but I can't help but notice that
for the first time in, like, several years,
you ended a video without saying, "John, I'll
see you on Tuesday."
Actually several nerdfighters noticed this,
and by several, I mean, these two people and
myself.
Anyway, leaving off the "John, I'll see you
on Tuesday" was definitely the correct artistic
decision, but it still felt weird to me and
it made me wonder why we have a sign-off in
the first place.
Like, Ze Franck’s ‘The Show’ inspired
most of the conventions of Vlogbrothers videos,
right.
Like the jump cuts, the ‘Good morning’
etc.
But Ze never had a consistent sign off, so
for a while I was, like, reveling in our originality
and creativity and then I remembered something
from the hazy distant past: ‘I gotta go’.
Now to the vast majority of you that means
I have to go but in fact I think it will mean
something else to Hank.
As an experiment I’m gonna call him right
now.
(On phone) I’m gonna call you back in about
twenty seconds.
I’m gonna play you a short audio clip and
I want you to, uh, video tape yourself.
OK, hold on.
Audio clip: And now here’s Ian.
Ian: I’m one of those guys who went to school
until I couldn’t get any more degrees.
Young people today could probably benefit
from my twelve years in college so here’s
some advice.
Avoid any course called Colonial American
Literature.
You will read smug creeps like Benjamin Franklin,
psychotics like Edgar Allan Poe, half-smart
mystics like Ralph Waldo Emerson and turgid
pulp writers like James Fenimore Cooper, all
of them dull.
John: What I’m hoping for is I’m hoping
you will remember the three word catchphrase
of that guy.
Hank: Is it 'I gotta go'?
John: YEAHHHH!!!
It is 'I gotta go'!
Hank: I don’t even know where that came
from.
John: Perfect.
I’ll talk to you later.
Hank: It’s deep, it’s deep in my brain
John.
John: Alright, I gotta go.
I gotta make, I gotta make a video.
So Ian Shoales was this public radio commentator
and when Hank and I were kids our parents
had his tape called ‘I Gotta Go’.
How do I explain tapes to young people?
They were kinda like Spotify only not free
and it only came with twelve tracks on it
and it was literally made out of tape.
It was very weird.
Anyway Hank, when I was, like, fourteen and
you were, like, eleven we listened to Ian
Shoales constantly and we loved him because
he was funny and he talked fast and he was
smart without seeming snobbish or inaccessible,
and plus he never got boring because his commentaries
were never more than four minutes long and
they always ended with him saying ‘I gotta
go’.
I mean Hank, we listened to that tape hundreds
of times, the fact that you remember ‘I
gotta go’ even though it’s been twenty
years since you last heard Ian Shoales say
those words, that says something.
And we were clearly hugely influenced by Ian
Shoales, not just because we have a sign off,
but because everything he was doing in 1985
is stuff that we’re trying to do now.
By the way Hank, it turns out that Ian Shoales
is a character created by a guy named Merle
Kessler who is still doing theatre and radio
work in northern California and who is still
very funny.
He’s still working, and his work is still
rippling outward, and, for me at least, that’s
the definition of a successful creative life.
In a recent episode of The Art Assignment
a viewer asked Sarah what her definition of
art was and she had this great answer about
being comfortable not having a definition.
And then I, like, blathered on for a while
without saying anything.
The thing is we tend to imagine creative enterprises
as, like, singular feats of genius, right.
You know, James Joyce, half-blind holed up
in an apartment writing Ulysses or Beyoncé
releasing a brilliant album without assistance
or warning.
But even if you’re James Joyce or Beyoncé,
your network of influence is vast and it stretches
back further than human memory.
In the Unites States it’s almost a national
obligation to praise individuals but in truth
I don’t think individuals really make stuff
so much as they process their influences and
try to build upon them in the hopes that they
can make stuff that will be helpful to others.
Contrary to the prevailing narrative, I don’t
think art is really a story of great individuals
trying to make their mark upon the world.
It’s really lots of people working together
across time and space trying to make the world
suck less for ourselves and for each other.
That’s my definition of art actually.
You can find a link to a couple Ian Shoales
commentaries in the dooblydoo.
Mr. Shoales, I'm a little bit embarrassed
that I’ve been making videos deeply inspired
by you for the past seven and a half years
without knowing it, but belatedly, thank you.
Hank, I gotta go.
Alright Hank, while I have this husky voice
I’m just gonna try and sing Whitney Houston’s,
uh, The Bodyguard song.
Ready.
This is just the refrain.
‘And I-ee-I will always love you-oooooo-ooo-oo’
(ooo barely audible and squeaky)
Didn’t get there.